[The Science and Art of Obstetrics]
[Laparotrachelotomy: Low, cervical cesarean section, by Joseph B. DeLee, M.D. and M. Edward Davis, M.D.]
[Taken at the Chicago Lying-In Hospital, Fox Movietone Scientific]
[...]
[Dr. DeLee appears, no audio present]
[Dr. DeLee:] ...in eighteen hundred and five.
And he did the operation,
he did the operation twice.
Both of the patients died,
but he realized that it was a step in advance,
and recommended it for all cases
requiring abdominal delivery.
The mortality of the
classic cesarean section
has improved as
time has gone on,
and it did not seem that we needed
a better method of abdominal delivery.
But, our ideas of what was good also improved.
In 1870, the mortality of 15 percent in Cesarean section was not bad.
In 1900, the mortality of four percent was considered excellent.
In 1930, a mortality of one percent is too much.
Therefore, when in 1906 Fritz Frank of Bonn
introduced the operation of Osiander,
the low cervical incision, it was eagerly seized
by the German operator, and its use has been spread over Europe
and now in the United States, it likewise
is receiving recognition.
The principle of
the new operation
is that the incision is made in the lower uterine segment,
the neck of the uterus,
and not in the fundus.
And all the superiority
of the new operation
grows out of this fact.
There are two kinds of low cervical Cesarean:
one where the incision being made just above the pubis,
approach to the
lower uterine segment
is gained by cutting through
the peritoneal cavity.
This is called the
intraperitoneal method.
The other kind is where the incision is made
just above the pubis, and the peritoneum
is pushed upward towards the navel...also the bladder.
And the bladder is pushed to the side,
and an area of lower uterine segment exposed,
sufficiently large for
the delivery of the baby.
This is called
extraperitoneal method,
the general peritoneal
cavity not being opened.
The majority of men prefer the direct route,
the intraperitoneal method.
The indications for the low
cervical Cesarean section
are exactly the same as for
the classic Cesarean section.
But owing to the safety
of the low operation,
we can extend the field
in which it may be done.
Now it is a fact that
in the United States,
too many Cesarean
sections are being done.
And it is also a fact that if the new operation
were generally practiced, the total number
of Cesareans done in the
United States would be reduced.
I shall have occasion to
refer to this point later on.
The contraindications to
the operation are very few.
In a woman with a
pendulous belly,
it may be hard to get access to
the lower part of the abdomen
to make the incision.
And if you are going
to do a Porro,
it is hardly worthwhile
to do the low operation.
But if at any time you
have to do the old classic,
make it as low in the uterus as
possible so as to get as many
of the advantages of the low
operation as are to be had.
Now a few words about the surgical anatomy.
Here is a model of a woman
at term, but not in labor.
Here is the cervix, and here the lower uterine segment,
which is about nine centimeters long.
This is variable, but it nearly
always is long enough for you
to extract the baby through it.
Here is the loop peritoneum over the lower uterine segment,
and here is the fascia, this white line,
the fascia that
extended from the vagina
upward, and loses itself towards
the fundus of the uterus.
It is about this point that
the grey seam is located.
You will hear a great deal about the grey seam
during the operation.
Here is a model of a woman who
has been in the second stage
for a long time.
And you can see how long
and thin the lower uterine
segment and cervix are.
They are fully 15 centimeters long,
and the lower uterine segment almost invites you to cut into it.
When you do your
first low cervical,
select the place
where the labor has
been on for a considerable
length of time.
And that makes it much easier.
You see how thin it is.
Here is the peritoneum again,
and here is the contraction rate.
Now gentlemen, a few words about local anesthesia.
It is particularly well-adapted to the low cervical cesarean section
And I prefer it to
the spinal anesthesia,
indeed to general
anesthetics, too.
No one can deny that
spinal anesthesia
is more dangerous than
a local infiltration.
And since we can, in 90 percent of the cases,
succeed with local
infiltration anesthesia,
this should be the
method of choice.
And I have here in my
hand the instruments
that we use at the
Chicago Lying-In Hospital.
They facilitate the operation,
but ordinary syringes
will do the work just as well.
We use a novacaine-cocaine solution, one half of one percent,
And we add two minims of adrenaline
to every ounce of the solution.
We use seven or eight ounces, sometimes nine or ten,
and we have never had any cases of poisoning,
or any trouble whatever.
After the baby is born, a
quarter of a grain of morphine
and 1/150th of scopolamine are given.
Solomon said that you should
have an understanding heart.
And this will help you a great deal in your
operating under local anesthesia.
No tugging, no pulling,
no jarring of the patient.
Gentleness all the time,
and you will succeed.
Now gentlemen, let us
proceed to the amphitheater
where we will do the operation.
Now Mrs. Herman, we
are ready to start.
Don't be afraid.
It will hurt just a little
when the baby comes.
I'll prepare you.
If any of my work should
give you pain, say ouch.
But don't move.
Pubis.
Navel.
We use a very fine needle to make a wheel in the skin.
Then the big needle doesn't
hurt when it goes in.
Inject the novocaine into the skin itself, and, of course,
into the fascia
right under the skin.
Inject as you move
the needle in and out.
Do you feel that?
[Patient:] No.
[Dr. DeLee:] Do you feel that?
[Patient:] No, Doctor.
[Dr. DeLee:] That's good.
You're going to see the grey seam,
where the loose peritoneum
of the uterus becomes firmly
adherent.
See how loose it is here?
...but I prefer the scissors.
[...]
On this drawing, you see where the clamps go,
and how the scissors cut the lower uterus in the front.
On this pelvis, you see how
the forceps are to be applied,
and the head delivered.
See the hammer
effect of the forceps.
Slowly, no hurry.
Now Mrs. Herman, the
baby is about to come.
Be brave.
Don't squirm.
Breathe quietly.
And in a very few moments, you will hear the baby cry.
[...]
I am putting my finger
in the baby's mouth
to bring it to the front.
Be careful,
you can injure the little mouth.
Wipe out the baby's mouth because if it gasps,
it might suck in the liquor amnii.
[Baby crying]
Lift the forceps blade
under the lip of the womb.
Be very careful of that.
Take lots of time,
very slowly and gently.
All the instruments have
been removed from the womb.
Slow...
Take lots of time.
No hurry.
[Baby crying]
Be ready to [INAUDIBLE].
Carmen, will you have a lap sponge [INAUDIBLE]
[Baby crying]
Now Mrs. Herman,
you go to sleep.
You have a fine, healthy baby.
And also, you had a hypodermic.
Gentlemen, we will now proceed to the repair of the womb.
In this animated drawing,
which Mr. Carlson made,
you will see the
course of the suture.
Avoid the mucosa.
Swing the needle around.
Now in the upper
part of the uterus,
the muscle is much thicker
and is likely to retract up
into the body of the uterus.
[Observer;} What kind of suture material
do you use, Dr. DeLee?
[Dr. DeLee:] We use number two catgut for the first row.
The second row,
we use number one.
And for the peritoneum, number one.
Very important to get a good apposition here,
in order to have a firm
scar in the lower portion
of the fundus and the cervix.
Don't catch the gauze in the needle.
Pull it out a little there.
The complications of the third stage...
very seldom is there
post-partum hemorrhage
in laparotrachelotomy,
especially if you use local anesthesia.
And we give ergot 15 minutes
before the baby is
born, and a [INAUDIBLE]
pituitary right afterwards.
If there should be hemorrhage,
we pack the uterus.
But I do that as a routine.
And if you wanted
to give pituitary
as it's been necessary, inject it under the peritoneum as...
I put it under the peritoneum.
because if the solution is infected and makes an abscess,
the abscess is not open
into the peritoneal cavity.
Some accoucheurs believe
that placenta previa is not
a good indication for
laparotrachelotomy.
But our experience in 40
cases without mortality
proves the contrary.
There are three or possibly four things that must be remembered.
In the first place,
in anemic cases
precede the operation by
a transfusion of blood.
And second, save blood
throughout the whole course
of the operation.
Don't waste any.
Third, deliver the baby
by version and extraction,
and proceed slowly so as
not to do any tearing.
Fourth, clamp all
the bleeding vessels,
and hold them securely clamped
until they are sutured.
Now gentlemen, do not
fear the difficulties
that you might encounter.
The field is open before you,
and you can meet the emergencies as they arise.
The hemorrhage, you can control by the ordinary tools and surgical method.
And mechanical difficulties
are overcome by taking time,
and by art instead of strength.
Let me again recommend
the low cervical cesarean
or laparotrachelotomy, as
well as the local anesthesia.
Any of the difficulties, an
ordinarily skilled surgeon
can overcome.
And if you will perform
this operation as a routine,
I am sure that you will
cut your mortality in half.
What are the particular
features of the low cesarean
that make it so superior?
As I said before the operation,
these points of superiority
grow out of the fact
that the incision is
in the lower uterine segment.
And I will now give you 10 of
these points of superiority.
The first point is that the
incision is in the lower
part of the abdomen.
All the surgeons know
that the lower abdomen
is more resistant to infection than the upper abdomen.
The intestines and the omentum will rarely come into view,
and are not touched.
Therefore, shock is small,
and there is less tendency to vomiting after the delivery,
and to ileus.
The spill is located
right around the womb
and has very little
distribution,
which also helps prevent shock, ileus, and nausea
and vomiting.
The cervix, in which the incision is made,
is more resistant to infection, being used to it.
Every gynecologist knows how
much the cervix can stand.
I will now show you
this on another chart.
This chart shows the delivery...
shows the uterus a few
hours after delivery.
As you see, the cervix shrinks
and drops into the pelvis,
out of the general
peritoneal cavity.
This was point five.
Point six. In this chart you see the uterus a few hours after delivery.
And as you will notice,
the wound in the cervix
has dropped down into the
cavity of the pelvis, far away
from the general peritoneal cavity.
That was point five in
the list of superiority.
One of the greatest
advantages of the low incision
lies in the security of the
scar in subsequent pregnancies
and labors.
Only a few cases of rupture
of the scar during pregnancy
have been put on record.
And the number of ruptures of
this scar during actual labor
is only a small
fraction of those
that occur after the
classic cesarean section.
The reason for this
security from rupture
is easily seen by a
reference to these charts.
In this operation, the wound is in the lower uterine segment,
which is at rest and
can heal in peace.
It is not disturbed by the turmoil going on in the fundus above.
Compare that wound with this, after the classic cesarean section.
Here, the wound
is in the fundus,
which is in a constant
state of unrest.
The uterine contractions,
the afterpain,
keep up a constant motion,
and sooner or later, one of these stitches or more
[INAUDIBLE] will tear, and
let the cut, the lochia
and bacteria into the wound
and into the peritoneal cavity.
Point of superiority,
number seven.
In the old classic cesarean,
the lochia has a chance to seep through the uterus
into the general peritoneal
cavity, causing peritonitis.
In the new operation,
the low cervical,
the lochia is prevented
from seeping through,
and is confined to the
neighborhood of the cervix
and under the bladder.
Should infection occur,
which is not common,
see how easy it is to drain
the area that is infected.
Either you can pull the
cervix down with a vulsellum
and make an anterior colpotomy,
thus reaching the abscess under the bladder,
or you can burrow a finger through the stitches,
into the abscess.
Or, what is most common, nature helps you
in that the pus burrows under the bladder, around the bladder,
through the cavity urethras.
And by taking out one, two
or three of these stitches,
you can let the pus out,
and usually, healing is very rapid and complete.
For comparison, see
where the infection
would travel after a
classic cesarean section,
beginning here in the endometrium,
all through the peritoneal cavity.
Adhesions are common after the classic cesarean section,
and the reason is very plain.
Then the infection and pus is in
the intestines and the omentum.
On the other hand, after the low operation,
adhesions are very rare,
and you can see why.
The wound is dropped down into the pelvis, far away
from the general peritoneal cavity,
and the omentum almost never comes down so low,
the intestines hardly ever.
And when the bladder fills, the peritoneal line of suture,
that little line of suture I showed you at the operation,
drops down into
a deep cul-de-sac
and is further protected.
Finally here, but there are many other reasons.
The classical cesarean section is only safe
when it is an operation of election.
We can give a woman
a good test of labor,
and then perform a low
cervical cesarean section.
And therefore, by giving
a woman a test of labor,
a great many cesareans will be unnecessary,
and thus, the total percentage in the United States
will be reduced.
Now gentlemen, in conclusion, I have here the mortality statistics
of the United States Census Bureau in Washington.
And from these
tables we can learn
that over 500 women die from
cesarean section every year.
This is an enormous
number, and brings upon us
the opprobrium of the community,
when our statistics of maternal mortality
are compared with those of other nations.
If laparotrachelotomy was generally practiced in the United States,
I am sure that most of this mortality would be reduced.
And this is the reason that I have spent
a great deal of time, a great deal of effort,
and not a little
money in spreading
the gospel of the low
cervical cesarean section,
or laparotrachelotomy.
[bells ringing]
Ladies and gentlemen,
it is now six years
since the picture which
you just saw was published.
And I am going to tell you what has happened to the operation,
laparotrachelotomy, during this time.
But first, I want to
show you those babies.
Boys, will you come in?
I believe that Cesones do better
mentally and physically than children delivered from below.
Attention, salute,
left face, march.
What has happened
to the operation
during these six years?
Several modifications
have been suggested,
and we have tried them.
But we have found
that the method
which you saw on the screen,
and which was perfected after 14 years of trial, is still the best.
For example, the transverse surgical incision, like this.
A transverse, curvilinear incision
is made above the bladder.
We tried the operation
10 times, and gave it up.
One severe hemorrhage from the
base of the broad ligament,
one dangerous
extension of the womb,
a big baby, twice difficulty
in suturing the upper
to the lower flap.
The upper muscular lamellae
had retracted into the funds of the uterus,
and one almost fatal pulmonary embolism.
The literature records the fact that there are
more pulmonary embolisms after the transverse incision
than after the longitudinal.
We had one embolism in
10 transverse incisions,
and we had only one
embolism in the 1,800
other laprotrachelotomies.
The surgeons or gynecologists
would be very happy
if they could record 1,800 consecutive laparotomies
with only one
pulmonary embolism.
This is the median incision.
If the baby is large, you
can extend it up or down
towards the cervix.
If a tear occurs, it does
not go into the basis
of the broad ligament where the big vessels and the urethra are.
If the wound should
get infected,
the dangerous areas, the big veins, are far away.
[Observer:] Doctor, do you still use packing?
[Dr. DeLee:] Oh, yes.
We pack the uterus routinely.
But we are now using
acriflavine, iodine,
and glycerine on the gauze.
I wonder if there really is
an antiseptic that does good.
But we have a better ergot preparation.
It is called ergonovine.
Regarding post-operative
adhesions,
we have done second and
third laprotrachelotomies
on 345 patients.
And we found adhesions
to be the exception.
Whereas, after the classic cesarean section,
adhesions are the rule.
And they not seldom cause
serious late complications.
Fertility, likewise,
is not compromised
by the low operation as
it is by the classic.
Rupture of the uterus in subsequent pregnancy and labor...
the cervical scar has
proven its superiority.
There are only three cases on
record of rupture of the scar
during pregnancy.
And during labor, there are
less than 50 cases on record.
Whereas the classic
cesarean is notoriously
dangerous in this respect.
There are thousands of
ruptures to its discredit.
[Observer:] Doctor, how about placenta previa?
[Dr. DeLee:] We have done 120 laprotrachelotomies
in placenta previa without a single death.
Some doctors claim that the
classic cesarean section
is better in this complication.
But we believe
just the opposite.
We want to make the
opening in the uterus
over the bed of the placenta, where we can attack
a hemorrhage should one occur.
You make the incision a little bit higher on the uterus than usual.
The bleeding is only marked
if the placenta happens
to be on the anterior wall.
You burrow through the
placenta, grab the foot,
and slowly bring the
breech into the opening,
just the same as you do
when delivering from below.
If, after the
placenta is delivered
the bed of the placenta bleeds,
you simply sew it up like this.
You see it is very easy
to stop the bleeding.
You lip over the bed of the placenta with number 0 catgut.
Regarding infected
cases, we have not
broadened the indication
for laparotrachelotomy
to cover the frankly
infected case.
But we have risked it,
even when the bag of waters
has been ruptured a long time,
when several vaginal examinations have been made,
when labor has been prolonged, and when forceps
has been attempted, providing there was a reasonable amount of cleanliness.
The Porro operation is still the best for the frankly infected patients.
But, although it is sad to have to say it,
craniotomy may still be considered in rare instances.
Local anesthesia.
Local anesthesia has
helped materially
to reduce our
maternal mortality.
It is better than
spinal in every way.
And even the neurologists
are telling us
of late diseases resulting
from this invasion
of the spinal canal.
Laparotrachelotomy is
the ideal cesarean.
And experience the world over has justified
all the claims we have made for it.
You remember I told
you that it would
cut your mortality in half?
Well, look at this chart.
City of Chicago,
1934, 490 classics.
Deaths, five and a half percent.
Laparotrachelotomies, 541, two percent.
Germany, classics 438.
Deaths, six and four-tenths percent.
Laparotrachelotomies, 3,554.
Deaths, three and seven-tenths percent.
Chicago Lying-In
Hospital, 1914 to 1936.
Out of 60,000 deliveries--
60,000 deliveries--classics 168, deaths six percent.
Laparotrachelotomies, eighteen hundred and eleven...one-thousand eight hundred eleven.
Deaths, 18 from all causes.
Tuberculosis, eclampsia, heart disease, et cetera, one percent.
Now ladies and
gentlemen, a final word.
I believe in view of all these facts,
that I may in all fairness
ask you this question.
Does a man, in performing the old classic cesarean section,
when the low cervical operation could be done,
does he give his
patient all the benefits
of modern obstetric art?
[Music]